- Ben Coleman, you
are the vice president
of the Los Angles Log
Cabin Republicans.
Gay Republican,
how do you exist?
- Here I am, I'm a
republican and I'm gay.
You know, being gay is
only one part of me.
Log Cabin Republicans
exist actually
to bring the Republican Party
closer on the gay issues
and kind of change hearts
and minds from within.
- The republicans
have come a long way.
- I think so.
I think there's
been an evolution.
- I actually can come a long way
but that's because I've been
eating a lot of potassium.
(laughs)
Was it difficult for you to
come out, as a republican?
- You don't really mention
that you're a republican, too.
But eventually--
- Because they might reject
you and not love you?
- Well--
- And I'd say that's unnatural.
- They might make fun of you.
- Yeah, no friend of mine
is gonna be a republican.
You get out and I don't
ever want to see you again.
So that must be
kinda hot, right,
you get one of these
libtards you know,
and you can just pound
it out, you know?
(laughs)
You know what I'm saying?
Do you feel that the
gay rights movement
has gone a little too far?
- I do, yeah.
- [Interviewer] In which ways?
- Well I think that they're--
- Are the shorts too short?
- (laughs) I think that the
gay rights movement over all,
has been pushing people
who are not yet ready
to understand what it even is.
There's a lot of people
who just don't understand,
two men together, they
just don't get it.
Or two women
together, et cetera.
- I get two women
together, but not two men.
It's like when it's two
girls though, it's like hot,
but when it's two
dudes I'm kinda like,
"I don't get it."
But when it's two
girls though, I'm like,
"I do get this."
You know, and I'll like,
crack open a Mickey's.
Is homophobia okay if it
serves the free market?
- If you walk into a
place as a gay person
and you're like, "I
want a birthday cake."
And someone says, "Well, I
don't serve gay people here."
I mean, I think that's a
pretty dick thing to do.
- Yeah.
- It's not very cool.
Should they be allowed
to do it under the law?
I tend to err on the side of no,
the law shouldn't force
them to have to serve
anybody they really
don't want to serve.
At the same time why
would this gay person
want to get a cake
from a nasty person
who hates them just
because they're gay?
- Hey, what if they
make a good ass cake?
You're not a believer in
climate change being manmade?
- Correct.
- So what's the agenda
of the climate scientist?
- Well if you're the scientist
that comes up with the idea,
that then changes the
way that people do things
across the entire globe,
doesn't that make you feel
like you're a powerful person,
you get accolades and
you're called upon
in congress to speak.
- It's for accolades?
- Yeah.
- If a politician is
actively campaigning
against gay rights and you
find out that that politician
is gay, is it now moral
to out that person?
- No, that's something they'll
just have to live with.
First of all it doesn't
make them anti-gay
to say I don't believe
in same sex marriage,
because there's a
lot of nuances there.
There's religion, there's all
kinds of things to consider.
- It seems to me like
the difference between
a person saying gay people
shouldn't be allowed
to get married and
interracial couples
shouldn't be allowed to
get married is negligible.
Seems like the same
kind of bigotry.
- Well, it's really not.
Saying that marriage,
which historically was
intended for procreation,
so a black man and a white woman
can get married and procreate.
Two men can not
do that naturally,
two women can not
do that naturally.
- If that is in
fact the litmus test
then we aught not to allow
barren women to get married.
- Well, and that's a good point.
- I think I've just
become a conservative.
Checkmate.
- No, checkmate.
- That's not how it works,
'cause I said it first,
so I checkmate you.
- Yeah, but if I say it last
before the SD card runs out.
- That's a good point,
but actually, checkma--